good morning
um
I'm venkat guruswami I'm a senior
scientist here at the assignments
Institute and it's my pleasure to
welcome you all to this week's Workshop
as you know um the Simon's Institute is
a leading uh International venue for
collaborative research in TCS it was
established in 2012 uh the generous
Grant from the Simon's foundation and
The Institute brings together the
world's leading researchers in theory of
computing in related fields as well as
the next generation of outstanding young
scholars in terms of postdocs and
fellows
so each semester we have two programs
that attract several long-term visitors
Junior and senior to the Berkeley campus
and which include multiple workshops
that also convene more short-term
visitors and these days we also have
regular summer activities including full
programs like the one-on analysis in TCS
this summer you know the weather may not
be like it but it is actually summer so
it's a summer program
so one of the inaugural programs hosted
by The Institute for those who might
recall was in Fall 2020 2013 and was on
real analysis in computer science so
it's a really nice to host this program
to wrap up 10 years of uh exciting
activities in the field
and um okay so now to this week's
program I'd like to welcome you to the
first Workshop of the analysis and TCS
program called beyond the Boolean Cube
and first I would like to thank the
organizers for their work in putting
together a great program and bringing
you all here
um so that those are door Windsor ishan
chateau padyai you're here raise your
hand get an Applause are you all filmers
uh Tali Kaufman and James Lee so thank
you all
[Applause]
and just a few uh logistics for the
coming week so food is provided before
the first talk uh and during the breaks
for lunch or on your own but there are
many options close by and we ask that
you please leave food and drinks
including coffee
um outside the auditorium and if you
want to store something when you go for
lunch or otherwise there are lockers on
the far side of the building to store
your stuff and all our talks as always
are live streamed and uh will be posted
on the YouTube channels or videograph
Romeo will help with any AV issues and
he's always on Deck and this I believe
this Workshop is also hybrid so the
session shares will be monitoring the
zoom Channel and
questions
and finally a special thanks to the
events Team without whom you know these
events cannot happen Ashley Hassan and
Elizabeth Ewan they manage all the
logistics locally here but also
accommodations for out on visitors and
all the things okay so let's give them a
round of applause
[Applause]
okay so with that I'll hand it over to
Door who will say a few workshops few
words about the scientific plans
thank you thank you all for coming and
those in Zoom also so uh today we're
going to have the first day of the
beyond the Boolean Cube Workshop so you
know we're on well no and love that
we're a cube you know it has uniform
measure it's all nice but sometimes you
need to go beyond it and you know recent
years they've seen some applications of
that to both you know when you consider
completely different domains and both
when you consider continuous versions of
the cube and we've seen some of these
ideas already in the boot camp
but this week is going to be mostly
devoted to ideas relating to that so I
hope that you'll find it interesting and
yeah so without that out of the way let
me introduce our first Speaker who will
tell us about explicit orthogonal and
unitary designs to take it away thanks
Dora thanks uh the organizers for
inviting me
um
yeah this is join work with uh Pedro
Princeton is right there and uh Rock
Oster video Colombia is right over there
uh
okay so let G be a group of n by n
matrices I always like to start a talk
that way with just a plain math sentence
but let me give you some examples uh
these are the examples you should have
in mind
um so this one is all the permutation
matrices it's just permutations of the
numbers one through n thought of as
permutation matrices that's SN
and the next example is actually the
example that originally motivated Us in
this work it's all the rotation matrices
the rotation matrices and dimensions the
fancy name of which is s-o-n
and then uh one for the quantum heads uh
the unitary Group which is basically
like all the rotations and N complex
dimensions
okay so these are all groups and you the
realized as n by n matrices
uh so you might remember the subheading
here was about pseudo-random rotation so
we're going to be thinking about
um drawing these in a random or
pseudo-random way so let's think about
the number of bits of entropy or the the
seed length if you're into pseudonym
generators needed to sample from the
uniform Distribution on the group okay
so for the permutation matrices there's
n factorial of them so you need log of n
factorial bits which up to logs is about
uh n Bits of randomness
now coming to these next two you know
star said we got to go beyond uh
discrete things these are actually
continuous groups so you know it's bad
for them to call it the uniform
distribution but there's a natural
distribution called the hard
distribution which I'm just going to
call the informed distribution that
talks that's like the uniform
Distribution on all rotations or all
unitary matrices
uh okay so how many bits of entropy do
you need to pick a random like rotation
Matrix well even this question is not
quite well posed because like a
continuous I mean there's a Continuum of
any
um rotation matrices well you know
morally speaking this is like an N by
end box of numbers it's like N squared
numbers and it should be fine to get it
to some I don't know Precision that's
like one of our ends so you should think
of like this requiring is something like
N squared bits of Randomness too
choose and same story for the unitary
group
uh okay I know we're supposed to go
beyond the Boolean queue but I have to
at least mention it once so everything I
say in this talk actually makes sense
and is applicable when the group of n by
n matrices is all the matrices whose
diagonal entries are plus or minus one
and that's just the Boolean Cube
um but everything I talk about won't
like really shed any new light or get
any new results about the Boolean Cube
so this will be the last time I mention
it in the talk and then we'll go beyond
it but here also you still need like n
Bits of Randomness to draw uniformly
um from this group
okay so what's our our goal uh our goal
is to come up with a
distribution G hopefully sample of all
with like lots of fewer bits of entropy
like way less than n Bits of Entry B
such that you know the the pseudo random
distribution is still some kind of
um model for the uniform distribution
and the precise sense of which we're
gonna like look for it uh this is we're
gonna hope that somehow the case moments
of uh a group Elementor Matrix drawn
from the pseudo random distribution is
close to what it should be with respect
to the uniform distribution and by case
moment it's really what I mean is um
every product of K entries from The
Matrix because all these group elements
are now thought of as like uh n by n
matrices
so maybe in more mathematical detail
um
you can actually make this Matrix I mean
given a group element X which is like an
N by n Matrix you can make this a matrix
X so the case tensor power like The kth
Chronic or tensor power of x
which is basically the the box of
numbers that include that encodes all
products of K entries from X
and on the right here we're going to
take the expectation of this you know
box of numbers over all uh over the
uniform Distribution on the group so
like in codes like all the expected
values of products of K entries from
your permutation Matrix or rotation
Matrix or unitary Matrix
and we want a pseudo-render distribution
on the group such that it's like you
know products of K entries have about
the same value up to some Epsilon
um okay one tiny comment if you're
working with the the case of the unitary
group uh where these entries have
complex numbers then you should really
look at products of like K over 2
elements from The Matrix times K over
two elements that are like complex
conjugated
but this is the last time I'll mention
this technicality
any questions about like the the rough
plan of what we're trying to do
this is kind of like um KY almost K-Y is
uniformity so if you're familiar with
this notion in the context of like
binary strings
um this is what we're going for so we're
trying to these are sometimes called
Almost uniform distributions over
the group or sometimes called
approximate uh K designs for the group
concrete case and the easiest one to
think about is maybe the case where it's
the permutation matrices and let me also
just for concreteness 6K to be four
okay so
um
you see if you have a permutation Matrix
X and you look at this like four-fold
tensor power
um it'll actually still be a matrix with
just zeros and ones in it and it'll you
know whereas the base permutation Matrix
has a one and like the IJ position if
the permutation Maps you know I to J
this will have like a one in the IJ or
i1 I2 I3 I4 position or you know these
eyes position in this J's position if
the permutation Maps these four eyes to
these four J's
um and then if you take the expectation
of that with respect to well any
distribution you get like the
the entries in code the probability
under your pseudorandom distribution
that you map these four numbers to these
four numbers and these are the things
that we want to
um approximately preserve with our
pseudorandom distribution
it's um particularly easy to understand
the right answer is supposed to be in
the the permutation Matrix case so if
you think about the what happens on the
uniform distribution
um you know at least if all these like
you know eight indices between one and N
are distinct then you know the
probability that a uniformly random
permutation will map these four eyes
these four J's is you know this number
one over n times one over n minus one uh
Etc and then you know when there's some
overlap you can figure out what the
correct answers are
so you know in this context we want to
suit a random distribution on
permutation such that
um you know for any four indices the the
probability they map to some other four
indices is about what it should be
um so while we're here let me discuss a
little bit about what we mean by uh
Epsilon approximate mostly I want to say
like uh don't don't worry about it too
much uh there's gonna be a lot of
parameters in this talk but
um you see these these numbers that
we're trying to match are like this one
is on the order of one over n to the
fourth or you know for General K would
be like 1 over n to the K so if you
think about like matching trying to
match this number you kind of at least
feel intuitively Epsilon should probably
be smaller than one over n to the K
right otherwise like this number is not
distinguishable from zero which seems
quite bad
um on the other hand uh you know if
Epsilon is like one over n to the 100K
that seems like it's you know doing a
very good job of matching it
um these are like n to the K many
numbers you're trying to match and then
like you know most are all the
applications I know this is about the
Epsilon you want to take anyway
and therefore for like the rest of the
talk I will just fix Epsilon to be like
1 over capital N to the 100K okay
so let me tell you what's known about
this topic of approximate K designs for
um for mutations and rotations and
unitaries
um okay so first one thing you can do if
you want this you know good to random
distribution is like the the cheating
inefficient solution where you like
at random pick a bunch of uh matrices
from the group and then fix that a set
of matrices and then say my pseudorandom
distribution is the uniform distribution
over this fixed set
so you can do that and it'll it'll
um you know do well but that's not an
efficient construction because like the
algorithm would have to like remember
this giant table of fixed random
matrices it shows but at least gives us
like the Baseline that we should be
trying to shoot for with in terms of
like how many bits of entropy we want to
uh strive to use when making our designs
and it's easy to show you're definitely
going to need at least like log of one
of Epsilon many bits of entropy even for
this solution and in our context where
we fixed Epsilon to be like this that's
K Times log of capital n
and I say capital N because now for the
rest of talk I'm going to ask you to
memorize that like capital n stands for
two to the little n
and um we are indeed going to be
thinking about like you know
pseudo-random distributions over like
giant uh I guess group elements like
think of them as exponentially large
permutations or or unitaries or rotation
matrices
so this is uh K times Little M so that's
basically uh like the dream amount of uh
seed length or entropy to shoot for
and let me tell you what's known so
let's start with the
um uniform almost ky's uniform
permutations which have some
applications here that I listed so
around 2005
um two different uh groups Kaplan or
rheingold and uh uh casabov you know
gave the the basically the dream result
they got this result with the entropy
being order KN so that's good
um okay this is also heavily studied uh
by Quantum people in the case of um
unitary matrices and there are like to
you know really think of the dementia
and capital N is two to the little n you
can think of it as like unitaries that
operate on N qubits if you know some
Quantum terminology
and uh in this context these works of uh
brandal Harrow hordecki and this is a
hopper Camp Hunter Jones and more Hafer
Camp
um they got close to the optimal bound
the entropy they use is like polynomial
and K and in n
and I should say like in this context
you know optimizing the number of bits
of entropy is not what they really cared
about it's more like a like something
you can observe about the result
um what they really actually just care
about is the following let's say you
want to make a unitary on N qubits just
by like making a a random Quantum
circuit yourself like n qubits you start
putting down like a bunch of random
Quantum Gates and you feel like if you
put down enough of them like it should
um be close to like a completely random
unitary
and
um one way to you know quantify that's
close to being a completely random
unitary is that like all the k-fold
moments are about what they ought to be
and
um that's what they you know were mostly
motivated by and
um so they showed that like a random you
just pick a completely random circuit
with like this many uh Gates then it's
uh approximate KY or k design for the
unitary group
and this is particularly nice because
the construction is then like strongly
explicit like even though it's a two to
the N by two to the N dimensional units
area you have this you know poly little
land size representation of it in terms
of a circuit
so at least for the permutation case can
you get Epsilon a zero can you get exact
Independence
uh when K is two and three you can uh I
think there aren't explicit instructions
no one's case at least
or well you should check this paper by
uh Shahar love it and no go alone
um that addressed this question
okay
so uh what do we do in our paper
um so we were really interested in
rotation matrices which is uh this SO2
the end group and actually I'll tell you
why um well okay let me first say that
like uh what do we do in the paper uh we
kind of get like the optimal results uh
with canned bits of entropy for the
rotation matrices and also for the the
unitary matrices
um I should know because it's very
important to the people that are
interested in unitary designs it's not
like we show like you can you know get
like a almost K design using fewer Gates
when you make your random Quantum
circuit it's still going to be like the
same you know number of gates like maybe
N squared Gates it's just we don't make
a completely random circuit we like have
like only a pseudo randomly chosen
circuit you think this many bits of
entropy that still has all the right uh
um case moments
um
yeah so just as an aside the reason we
were I mean got started this whole
project is we're interested in this
paper by
um pravesh kothari also here in Ragu
Mecca about pseudonym generators for
spherical caps and they got these almost
optimal random generators um conditioned
on this result so like assuming uh there
is a result like this with the optimal
seed length for random rotations
um they got these almost optimal prgs
for spherical caps so this result is now
unconditional
um okay any questions
okay
so in the first part I'll tell you about
um some de-randomization techniques
that go into it so uh let's just take
this part of the the table
and remember I said that the way the the
construction went for unitary matrices
the previous one is just like making a
random Quantum Circuit of like randomly
placed Gates
and interestingly enough you know like
25 years before
uh the exact same construction was
proposed in the context of the
permutation matrices by gowers who it's
actually motivated by cryptography
and this first paper by gowers was
literally like I will make like a random
you know classical reversible circuit so
like a random circuit with like n Bits
where each gate is like a permutation on
let's say three bits so it's like an
eight by eight permutation
and uh he showed the exact kind of
similar result with like poly K and poly
end here if you make a random
permutation on the N bit strings in this
way
um it'll be close to you know ky's
uniform
and the subsequent papers by like hurry
at all and Broski huri um like improved
these exponents
right yeah is he known that N squared is
the best you can do when you just
combine random Gates uh no actually at
the end I'll mention a fact which I'll
spoil now which is to say that actually
um like the number of gates you you need
[Music]
constructed the N cubed
um what we actually know about the the
the permutation Matrix case is actually
a bit worse than what we know in the the
Unitarian orthogonal case
um yeah so I'll mention that again at
the end
um so uh the way coupling Oren Ringwald
proved their results with like sort of
optimal entry is just taking this more
or less as a black box and applying some
de-randomization techniques on top of it
and they do randomization techniques are
like pseudo-random walk generators or
like uh alternatively steer randomized
squaring of graphs techniques introduced
by like reingold and Luca and
um but Don and this is uh rosenmann and
budon
um you kind of have your choice of
techniques we like to use this the
randomized squaring of graphs technique
um
I'll tell you a little bit about that on
upcoming slides but um one observation
we made in the paper I don't think it's
like a super novel observation but
um we recorded the fact that this D
randomized squaring of graphs even
though it has the word graph in it it's
not really about graphs I mean if you
think about like a like the random walk
Matrix for a graph a regular graph it's
just like the average of permutation
matrices at least if it's like a
a Cali graph or an edge colored graph
and we just observed that like all this
paper about the randomized squaring of
graph also works for like the randomized
squaring of averages of bounded
operators
um
so we'll use that in our context where
we don't have graphs
this will maybe make hopefully a little
bit more sense as I go on
and like let me tell you a little bit
about how this uh the randomization tool
goes
so remember a goal is saying the cables
4ks is to come up with some low entropy
distribution pseudo on the group G such
that
um uh these two you know matrices are
boxes of numbers are almost the same
when you draw from the the pseudonym
distribution or the uniform distribution
let me just make a definition for this
expression X tensor X tensor X sensor X
I'll call it R of x
and um to be a bit fancy this is a
representation of the group G
which just means that like R of X Y is
the same of R of x times R of y That's
How multiplication of these tensor
products works
uh okay so we can also write this
quantity which is sort of like our
Target like blocks of numbers is the
expected value of R of X under the
uniform distribution and also just even
call that uniform average sub R that's a
matrix
um
okay this is a very basic fact about
groups that we'll use
um in any group if you fix some group
element x0 and then you draw a uniformly
random element X and then you look at X
zero times x the distribution of that is
always still the uniform distribution
you know independent of what x zero was
just basically follows because you know
there are inverses in groups
and if it's a non-abelian group it's
also the same if you multiply on the
right
and um by the way this is basically I
mean we'll be talking later about
rotation matrices and the unitary
matrices where the uniform distribution
is really the harder distribution and
like this is basically the definition of
the hard distribution that it like
satisfies this property
um if you do any fixed rotation and then
do a uniformly random rotation the
combination of them is the uniformly
random rotation
okay so um as a corollary of that if you
think of this uniform average of r as
like a matrix
and you multiply it on the left by R of
any fixed um group element X zero you
get back this uniform average
because you know here's the definition
of the uniform average if you like stick
r at zero on the left leg here x0 is uh
not doesn't depend on X you can bring it
inside
and then you can use this rule and then
you can use this back that like x0 times
x is distributed as uniform again so
that's why it's true
um
okay actually therefore I mean this is
true for literally every fixed x0 every
fixed group element that's zero so it's
also true like for any distribution of
our group elements
or as a corollary if we have
um the average of R of X under any
distribution that's still a matrix kind
of a matrix of kth moments uh under the
distribution times this uniform average
Matrix then you get back the uniform
average Matrix
and as a further corollary about I mean
one distribution is the uniform
distribution itself so if we just plug
that in we get the uniform average of r
squared is the inform average over r
so uh this is a matrix and particular
that means like this is a projection
Matrix
[Music]
is in the case of like K being one and
it being the the permutation matrices
it's the uniform average of like a
permutation Matrix
which is like the Matrix where every
entry is one over capital N it's like
projection on the uniform distribution
would be in this case
yeah
yeah so when you look at
see here RX is a full answer
four matrices what does it mean to
what is the product operation
um which product operation like uh
zero times unicorn average of R uh this
is like a matrix so like think of X is
an M Matrix this is like an N to the
fourth by into the fourth mixture okay
oh
so just uh well just remember and leave
these facts like literally on the next
slide and then we can predict them so
just remember them if you would
right okay so this is our goal and the
entropy distribution signal random
distribution on G which is that the
pseudo average like the average under
the pseudonym distribution of The RK
representation where RK is like this K
sensor power of X is you know close to
what it's thought to be
okay so here's the plan
you can find like a real baby sit around
the distribution it's not gonna be the
final two random distribution doesn't
really like super weak pathetic baby
distribution
sample of all with very few bits of
entropy
and uh
we're gonna the main work will be to
show that
um if you average these like case
moments over the baby distribution it's
like not maximally terrible it's like a
teeny bit close to what it ought to be
the average of the cape moments under
the uniform distribution and here we are
I'm gonna explicitly say in what sense
of gloves like this is a matrix this is
a matrix I want the operator normally
difference to be a little bit less than
one
what you should think of it is like just
slightly vaguely close to the correct
answer
so um imagine for a moment that we have
this and now I'll start talking about
like um later we'll talk about how to
get this I mean spoiler it's like from
choosing some like random circuits
um but like now I want to tell you using
the randomization techniques how you can
improve this and get the full desire to
suit a random distribution
so okay this is a matrix and we're
imagining it's operator Norms at both
one minus Delta so we Square this Matrix
operator normally one minus Delta
squared
and what's going on with this squared
Matrix here let's just expand it out
um okay we got like the baby average
squared minus baby average times uniform
average minus the other way around plus
the square of the uniform average
um but if you remember the previous
slide like any average time uniform
average equals uniform average and that
happens on the left and right
and we well you can use it again here
these three are all the uniform average
and we got like two minuses and one plus
so it turns into a minus
and uh yeah so this expression equals
the square of baby average minus the
uniform average
so you can put that back in
and but then what is this beta average
squared Matrix okay and maybe average
squared like well I mean baby average is
like you just pick X1 for the baby
distribution and look at this r k of X1
we're squaring in so let's multiply it
by the same thing with just a different
letter
but then like X1 and X2 you could take
them to be independent and um then put
these two together on the inside and
then it's a representation
um so what you really got is like the
expected value of you know the case
moments are K of X or X drawn from what
I'll call the baby Squared Distribution
and the baby Squared Distribution is
draw one from the baby distribution draw
again for the baby distribution and then
multiply the results together
that's the baby Squared Distribution
so this is a distribution that you can
sample with two contest bits of entropy
so you know you've had baby required
aspects of entropy and it's kind of like
a teeny bit close to what you want when
my filter and now if you just draw from
it twice and multiply them together
um it's two aspects of entropy and you
get like you know a little bit better
so you can see the obvious thing to do
with this you can like I don't know
repeatedly Square the distribution or
like raise it to like you know the teeth
power that's distribution
and uh if you raise it to power T you'll
need s times T bits of entropy and you
know we're trying to get y minus Delta
down to Epsilon
and so you need to raise it to a power
that's like 1 over Delta to get the
center of constant and then log one
repsilon to get the snap Epsilon so do
you need like this many bits of entropy
if you just do a bunch of times from
baby and multiply them together
and this is where the de-randomization
comes in like instead of repeated
squaring you should do de-randomized
swearing and I'll just say in words like
what that means briefly without getting
into it but the effect is like it has
this effect that like you know you might
recognize if you've done like a little
bit of de-randomization it's like oh
instead of s times like log one reps
along over a Delta like in the D
randomized squaring you just need like S
Plus like log one over Epsilon plus log
one over Delta to get the same effect
and I'll just say in words briefly what
the randomized squaring is
um you know when you square the baby
distribution imagine the baby
distribution is like uniform
distribution or a fixed set of like baby
elements so baby distribution is uniform
over the fixed set of baby elements and
the squared baby distribution is like
pick two times from this fixed set and
then multiply them together
the randomized squaring is like take all
the elements in the baby distribution
and put like an expander graph down
whose vertices are the baby matrices
and then pick a random Edge in the
expander graph
and multiply the matrices Associated to
its endpoints
e randomized squaring
and
um if you repeatedly de-randomized where
you can get this kind of result
I won't really say any more about this
part and I'll just be like here's the
upshot
um
upshot is this
uh we get the desired strongly explicit
uh K times n bit entropy distribution
provided we can find like a sufficiently
good like baby distribution and what is
sufficiently good
um it's just enough for this Delta to be
like bounded by like one over
this should Clearly say greater than or
equal to uh should be at least one over
poly K poly n
and like you just need to like not need
too many bits for the baby distribution
like let's say at most n in fact it's
going to be logarithmic in our baby
distribution
so uh yeah in some sense like that's
most of what I'm going to talk about for
like the randomization tools and like
well just think about this as like the
new goal
yeah yeah so yeah you I I tried to like
get around them by saying upshot yeah
first of all yeah it's suspicion for S
to be like smaller than n k in our
actual application it's gonna actually
be logins it'll be like far from this
you might also like you're very sharp
like think like oh like we could have
got like Delta like it would have been
okay for adult to be way smaller than
this and we'd still be okay but
um you don't really want that because
like
um
even though like this is the number of
like uh pseudo random or truly random
bits you need the um number of product
like the number of things you multiply
together is like polynomial and one over
Delta
so even though you only need this many
bits so if you want your like eventual
construction to be kind of like
efficient you want polynomial in one
over Delta to not be like polynomial and
NK
um which is why this is actually why you
want Delta to be at least this big
yeah very quick with the parameters
they're young
that's good
okay
great so now I'm going to talk about uh
what is the baby distribution for all
these like settings of
um permutation matrices and rotation
matrices and unitary matrices and it's
actually going to be pretty much the
same in all three cases
I sort of already said what it was but
let's talk about it
um right so you know this was our goal
and I guess what I want to say is like
we'll get this like you know a goal of
having like the best uh entropy
um as long as we can get like a pretty
good baby distribution so let me talk
about this like uh pretty good baby
distribution in the context of
um the Unitarian group
like actually it's like the biggest of
all these groups like actually the
rotations and the permutations are
themselves unitary so we'll start at the
the
the mother of all these groups
right so in this context what do we need
we need this like cheap baby
distribution
on N qubit Quantum circuits we're going
to sort of use the fact that like every
unitary Matrix into the end Dimensions
um can be sort of expressed with n qubit
Quantum circuits
touch that like like the the cave
moments under the baby distribution are
like vaguely close in this sense to uh
the cake moments under the truly uniform
distribution of our completely random
Unitarian
um
okay so how are we gonna get this
well uh yeah sorry for like the non
Quantum fans but funnily enough like we
have to it's it's most convenient to
like talk about like Quantum computation
uh somehow embedded even this problem
just about like rotations and stuff that
we were working on
um so you know if you've seen like
Quantum computation 101 you probably
know this fact which is that um you know
basically every unitary Matrix and two
to the N Dimensions can be you know
computed or like arbitrarily well
approximated by
um you know multiplying together like uh
tiny little unitaries in like a Quantum
circuit so there's like a fixed set of
like Quantum you know Gates which are
like little unitaries that operate on
one or two or three qubits or like two
or four or eight dimensions
um that are Universal
and uh here's an example like proved
this uh particular family of uh
unitarius is like the toefully gate and
like the C not gate and the not Gates
and hadamard Gates
and the face Gates
um these gates are sufficient to like if
you multiply them together enough to get
like basically any unitary
read all your Quantum computation with
these Gates
and just to really clarify what it means
like this is a picture uh of a Quantum
circuit it has like n uh qubits are
depicted as wires and like each of these
like red rounded rectangles it's like uh
like a gate this is supposed to be like
a three cubic gate or an eight by eight
unitary operated on these um tensor
factors or qubits
and uh you know they get all multiplied
together
um it's very hard to depict like a a
gate that's operating on non-contiguous
qubits we got to do it so like this is
my attempt to draw a gate that like
operas on this key with this qubit and
this qubit and similarly let's keep it
the key business qubit
and you also might note that in this
picture like I depicted all the gates as
though they have like three qubit inputs
um whereas you know back in the set like
some had like this is like a three cubic
game but these are two in one but it's
okay without loss of generality just
imagine these all operate on three
qubits like if you have like a c naught
gauge just like pick another cubic gate
and like do the identity on it so I'll
henceforth depict all these
um uh little Gates as being three qubit
gates
okay
right so we know that you can eventually
get like more or less any unitary by
like you know multiplying together
enough Gates we want this cheap baby
Distribution on and qubit circuits that
does like something
and so the the natural distribution is
to literally just pick one gate that's
the whole distribution like you have n
you know qubits pick uh three of them
like uniformly at random and pick you
know random gate g from this set of six
matrices or whatever I had before I put
it down that's the whole circuit that's
your giant unitary
um
okay
and uh it kind of should even make sense
right like if you remember like not the
de-randomized squaring just think about
the squaring uh or the powering of like
the baby distribution it's like the
final version was like you drew many
times from this baby distribution and
like multiplied the results together
that's literally like you know just like
making a circuit where you just like
randomly place like a bunch of little
Gates so it's it kind of makes sense
so we kind of really need to analyze now
like what are all the cape moments of
like this giant unitary that you get
when you just plunk down like one random
gate
and uh this by the way we need this baby
distribution to be like cheap to
generate and it's very cheap to generate
like you just pick the position of the
wire so like log n cubed possibilities
plus you need to pick like which gate it
is so it's it's very cheap to generate
yep
uh yeah I'll mention that the question
was like you know why do we pick uh only
from like this fixed set if I understood
the question you know maybe we should
have just picked like a totally random
like three qubit unitary that's that's
like a constant sized object that should
be fine
um we will eventually get to that
um I guess
um you have to be a little bit careful
because like strictly speaking it's
although it's a constant sized object
you know you need to worry about like
what are the Precision I need for all
the entries so that like when I multiply
them all together
um I get like you know an Epsilon
accurate answer and our Epsilon is like
very very small actually so you have to
think a little bit carefully about like
how many bits of precision you need to
choose like all your entries and
um we're eventually going to sidestep
that
so it's actually kind of nice that you
have this discrete set because then like
you might even worry like oh if I'm
trying to choose like a you know
pseudorandom rotation matrices or
unitary matrices like I'm on a discrete
computer how do I output these matrices
yeah recall them has to have a sum of
squares equals one we output them like
literally in a completely exact and
precise format as Quantum circuits with
like discrete Gates I mean just
symbolically say like this is the out of
our gate and see if like symbolically
represented the unitary
okay
good so this theoreon that you need is
exactly what was done in this like paper
by Randall Harrow and Michal kordekian
uh had some quantitative improvements by
um
Hopper camp and Hunter Jones
uh and it's even nice there dependence
on Anne with quality linear here
um
but as I said before interestingly this
is also literally exactly what like
gowers did with the permutations way
back before like you can literally say
like just go back to this set of gates
that we were using
uh
like that's that's not permutation
Matrix that's not permutation Matrix so
these ones are so just keep these three
and like multiply them together like and
make a random
um in this way like make an N bit input
input output like representation of a
permutation Matrix on N bit strings
and uh yeah what he showed was the
analogous result that
um its Cape moments are like a little
bit close to what they ought to be
and yeah and the work with Pedro and
Rocco we did the same thing for rotation
matrices and they are like a similar
like just delete the phase gate the one
that puts the the eye into the picture
all the other ones are orthogonal Gates
um
yeah
okay so I'll tell you a little bit about
how we
do this any questions yeah do you need
the N2 bits Dimension just to be
convenience
that's right
oh yeah actually this is actually a bit
of an annoyance slash not exactly cheap
but um
we it's natural like if you want to like
sit around rotation matrices like any
Dimension like why is that to be a Power
of Two
it's kind of inconvenient like it's not
a power of two and we it's like
inconvenient enough like we did not
pursue like trying to deal with it
similar with the Kaplan or rheingold if
you look at the paper it actually only
give you pseudorant permutations when
capital N is like a power of two
um some of these works like the
unitaries like do say like oh we'll use
like Q dits so like maybe these are like
um you know like cute tricks and then
you get like powers of three
um
yeah it's a little bit annoying because
it's very convenient to have this like
framework of like you know tensor
factors of q-dips or qubits annoying
enough that we didn't try to investigate
that so it's it's kind of an open
question I suppose
yeah so if you unwind this uh
amplification you did your basically
your basic circuit will just be placing
many of these random Gates right yeah
but in a pseudo-random fashion
oh yeah
yeah the depth would be linear uh uh the
depth will depend on like what this uh
is
um so buy it basically like if you don't
in some sense forget the pseudo
randomization for a bit like
um the depth will be
uh like log one over Epsilon times one
over Delta
so
uh
I have to think about it a little bit uh
maybe I got this a little bit wrong but
basically like this you know the
reciprocal of this like does control the
depth of your random circuits you need
to end times policy just to get the
constant away from one yeah and then it
depends on what episode you need to get
that's right so if you want like quite
good for example
um unitary designs
uh you need well at least what's known
is like on the order of N squared Gates
because you need like you first like
kind of need to like touch every single
wire and plus you need to do more to
like make them good so they're like
um yeah N squared gates at depth and
so that's nothing known for unitary
okay so uh yeah I'm gonna tell you about
how to do this and you might actually
might stop me and say like you know look
um you know these these Quantum people
already did it for like the unitary
group you wanted it like our initial
motivation was rotation major so you
want to do it for the rotation matrices
these are like kind of similar groups
right like isn't it kind of the same
and uh yeah I'm not gonna deny this kind
of similar
I don't know like our proof gives like a
unified analysis of both like the
rotation matrices and the unitary
matrices and we make the primers a
little bit better and I think it's like
a little bit simpler and cleaner than
how it was done in the previous paper so
awesome tell you about this subject I
won't deny this
okay well you know I have like um not
that much time left uh so I'll tell you
about the outline of the proof but this
will be
um a very impressionistic because this
is my PowerPoint skills uh I only have a
little bit of time
foreign
[Music]
yeah we want to compare the baby
distribution where you put a plunton
down a random gate versus like this is
how I'll imagine the uniform
distribution imagine you plunk down like
an n qubit gate which is itself like a
uniformly random Gates that's a truly
uniform unitary
um okay and we want to show that this is
like at least this much as random as
this that sounds like a vague English
language sentence I'm going to use this
sentence a lot uh it has a real meaning
which is that uh when you average this
distribution this k-fold representation
and subtract that from the identity
Matrix to get a kind of laplacian like
the associated Matrix should be at least
this factor in the PSD order times the
thing with the uniform distribution
never mind this math I'll just use this
phrase in the future
um okay so step
proof it's exactly related to the
question from over here I mean the first
thing we do in the baby distribution is
pick a random you know three qubits
plunk down a gate from this discrete set
it might be like nicer to plug down like
a truly uniform uh three qubit gate
instead and one can show that like this
is at least constant Factor Universal
constant as random as uh this
which is good
this follows from like a like a powerful
arithmetic combinatorics type theorem
improved um by Bourdain and gambard in
the context of the unitary group and by
benue and dyslexia in the context of
General compact simple lead groups which
rotation matrices are
so we'll just use that and uh that gets
us from this picture to this picture
you should maybe think of intuitively as
not such a big deal like you feel like
you could draw like a three by three
unitary pretty well
which features of your bases do you need
to use it oh excellent question you need
to use that as uh dense which is like a
universal
also amusingly you need that the entries
of the matrices are algebraic numbers
which luckily I and you know square root
of a half are
that's fun
okay uh
okay so now it Remains the show that
like picking three qubits and plunking
down a random unitary is at least one
over n as good as picking all the qubits
and plugging down a random unitary so
it's going to be an inductive proof
inductive in terms of n
um I told you step zero
so let's skip to the end let's skip to
step n
in Step n uh we're going to consider
this distribution where you pick a
random uh wire ignore it and put down a
random unitary on the remaining n minus
one wires this is pretty random you just
like
kind of not randomizing one qubit
and we want to compare this to the fully
uniform distribution and you might
hopefully we'll get the intuition that
these should be reasonably close and
indeed like this number is going to be
pretty close to one
um and the main this is like the induct
doing this is like the induction step so
like the main technical pages of the
proof are like trying to prove a theorem
uh like this comparing this distribution
to this distribution and for every n
it's going to get bigger better like the
the bigger n is and in fact let's just
denote by Tau and like the best thing we
can eventually prove in the main
technical part of the paper of this
nature
okay
so let's assume for a second that we've
done that and now I'll tell you the
induction in a couple of slides
let's step n let's talk about Step n
minus one which is about comparing this
distribution where like
um you pick two wires to Omit and put a
random unitary on the remaining wires
versus you pick one wire to Emit and put
a random unitary on uh the remaining
wires and this is actually a claim I
claim that follow from the previous
slide this is at least whatever Tau n
minus 1 is as random as this
and let me try to intuitively convince
you of that claim
Fusion like you pick a random wire to
ignore and a remaining n minus one wire
is you plunk down a truly random unitary
and kind of on the last slide we imagine
we proved that like whenever you're
plunking down a truly random unitary
it's almost as good to like plunk down
like a random unitary except you omit
one wire
so like in this distribution where we're
like omitting one wire it ran and then
plunking down an N minus one qubit
unitary
let's replace the second half of that
step of plunking down the N minus one
water unitary with uh the the weaker
thing from the previous slide where you
like omit one further wire and plunk
down an N minus two qubit unitary there
and that's just the same as distribution
because like you randomly omitted two
wires so like inductively like if you
proved like us you know if you've got
this function Tau of n then like this
compared to this is just Tau of n minus
one
okay you have to be a little careful to
make sure that makes sense but it does
turn out to make sense
um and then you can put these things
together and compare this like Miss 2
case with like the Miss nothing case and
the factor is like Tau n minus one times
Tau n you can check
and I hope the induction is kind of
clear you'll like you know omit like
another wire and omit another wire
and you'll have it usually get down to
like omitting like n minus three wires
and you'll be in this position where
you're comparing just pick three random
wires and put down a random three qubit
unitary gate on them and I want to
compare that to like put down like a
random and qubit unitary gate
and the factor you get will be the
product of all these like Taos and these
tiles are less than one so it's getting
smaller and smaller and it's getting
worse and worse but like hopefully
you know as long as it doesn't go to
zero or like it's a little bit big it's
good
right so now I'll tell you about these
tiles and like these two theorems I'll
just put them both up are like this is
the main technical uh part of the paper
so theorem one is that all these towers
are always at least 0.04 and this is
just some number that popped out of the
calculations but it's least some
Universal constant so like no matter
what and KR particularly independent of
K these are all at least 0.04 so like
okay you could multiply together n
copies of 0.04 and get exponential and
little n that's not great
but theorem 2 it's like different
techniques we showed that like once you
know you're at like a large enough n or
M let's say you know like you're you're
randomizing almost everything so you
should feel like it's it's pretty good
um as long as 2 to the m is bigger than
K squared it's not even that clear where
K is anymore what we're doing is like
looking at the cape moments of these
distributions as long as um m is big
enough compared to K squared this is
ultimately a bit like a birthday Paradox
thing uh Tau m is at least like one
minus one over m
and uh that means m is at least two log
K and now you can just do the math
um for the first log two log K many you
know indices like you're forced to use
this one 0.04
um but that's okay this gives you like a
factor of one over poly k
and then for all the remaining ones you
can use this better bound and you get
like this and this telescopes it's
telescopes to
um I don't know M minus one over n which
is at least one over n so that's how you
get one over poly K order it
that's the outline of the proof all the
actual work in the proof is to approve
these well most of the work is to prove
these two theorems
okay look we're almost out of time so
like you know I can't I can't I can't
tell you about that anyway you're
probably tired you're tired of the
stupid baby you got like a side eye
about the coffee cup that's out there
so I'll just wrap it up
um
Yeah final comments I got like two more
slides
um
you know these are the two theorems that
we have to eventually prove I'll tell
you a teeny bit about what goes into
them
um
this one is uh this one is independent
of K kind of doesn't really mind so much
what the distribution is
um
or what the representation is
uh this one's like a coupling argument
it's kind of nice I mean all these
arguments we borrowed and modified from
like halfer camp and
um ran out at all it's like a coupling
argument that shows that if you draw
like twice from this distribution like
you can couple a little bit
and uh this one is like some linear
algebra and it really actually heavily
relies on like knowing what are all the
case moments like what is this Matrix
you're eventually trying to match the
expected value of the cape sensor power
of a uniform be random unitary or
rotation Matrix or whatever
um it's a little bit of representation
Theory it gets involved to know like
what is this projection Matrix that
you're eventually
trying to match
um so just some final comments
you know we tried to like do this in a
unified setting where we cover the
rotation matrices and unitary matrices
at the same time in fact these are both
like compact knee groups so like we're
like oh let's try to do this in a
general setting you know I kind of
discovered maybe I didn't know this
before but like you think this is like a
fancy definition that should have lots
of instantiation but there's basically
only like three compactly groups
um you know here's some slides that like
a top expert Mark meckis like gave like
a couple years ago about this setting
and he's like listen like our main
characters are just these two groups
your orthogonal group and the unitary
group actually you call the special
orthogonal group The Kid Sister of this
group
um and as he said they look a lot alike
but there are some subtle important
differences which I agree we had to do
like some different things So eventually
we had like you know a unified framework
that you know at the end like diverged a
bit between these two groups and how you
improve these results
um it's funny if you go on to read a
little bit more from this he's like
there's also this weird Uncle no one
talks about the compacted Groove that's
the other third it's my picture of the
weird uncle
especially opinion of both fighter and I
think it is weird to be a bull fighter
so I don't mind putting up this painting
um so just for it to be perverted we
decided to try to also do it for a
complex infected groups with like no
real application but we couldn't even
get started because like somehow it's
like not closed under like even
tensorizations this like plan of like
having like a circuit you know simplexic
qubit model didn't get off the ground so
I guess it's still an open question if
you can figure out an application of it
um and just for one more upload question
you can also try to do the permutations
um which is quite natural via this plan
so this is not really how gowers did it
um he did use like a path coupling
argument but it wasn't so much like this
and um yeah it was like a different
argument so you can try to do the um
permutations in the setting two but we
couldn't
try very hard but we couldn't do it
um this particularly seems a bit unclear
in this setting
um so it's kind of an open problem I
mean if you want a problem to think
about
um for the baby distribution defined by
like just one randomly placed classical
reversible gate
um sort of the best like spectral Gap is
not known so like we got this you know
basically one of our linear and N in the
Unitarian rotation case but um the best
thing that uh I guess is known for broad
skin who are you has an N squared here
and it kind of means that if you want to
make almost ky's uniform permutations in
this random circuit way you need like n
cubed Gates rather than N squared Gates
so this is like a fun kind of new like
maybe ish markup chain on permutations
that
um perhaps you'll enjoy thinking about
yeah that's it oh thanks
[Applause]
questions any questions following yep
are those interesting objects as well
like the distribution was passed by the
minus one oh pseudo random pseudo
distributions
uh yeah I don't know anything about it
and I can imagine there could be some
applications
so it sounds like a good question but I
know nothing about it I see so I was
thinking about like weighted prgc right
questions
yeah the other question so uh would you
results imply uh that let's say you take
a bunch of uh pseudo random or common
matrices and you look at say like that
with the special Norm match that of uh
if you look random
our spectrum of polynomials as a test
function
something that this is
I don't know except insofar as you can
try to use like the trace method and
this is the sort of thing you need for
the trace method
that's all I can say
to be honest probably you would know
better but uh yeah it's also I mean I
think interesting to think about other
uh ways to try to measure like
pseudonyms this is a pretty weak notion
uh but you know the advantage you can do
with very few random bits so
it's also a big question
yeah like do you use this fact that like
small subsets of like unitary matrices
look like independent gaussians like
where is this K square like this two to
the N bigger than K squared
that's of the proof
um
this Matrix this prediction Matrix which
is the average of this over All Uniform
distribution of like the capable tensor
power is
projection onto the span of all vectors
which are fixed by all matrices of the
site like let's say unitary two
rotation Matrix locate tensor power
and um the nature of such uh the nature
of those vectors are understood it's
like kind of the things that look like
uh
I don't know like um
like I'll be put together like maximally
entangled States according to like um
matchings
and
as M gets like bigger and bigger and
bigger
um these um fixed vectors like the one
eigenspace for this Matrix which is
found by these fixed vectors
um they have a natural description they
become like almost orthogonal and so
like it's very hard to like literally
understand a projection onto their span
but like
um if you just like pretend that these
like Matrix or vectors are the fixed
vectors that whose fan is the whole
Space
um were they're almost an orthogonal
basis and so like you can compete with
them and analyze with them and like uh
bigger m is the closer they are to being
a truly a problem basis and somehow that
closeness is where K comes
foreign
but actually it's sensible to even have
K bigger than two to the end
um you can take it so yeah it can be
whatever you want
um
yeah we'll just make a parameters
okay thanks very much
okay we'll come back at 11.